[Música]
vivimos una vida de suposiciones en la
cual nos toca tomar muchas decisiones y
generalmente tomamos el escenario
negativo por ejemplo me gusta una chica
y pienso y si yo no le gusto veo una
convocatoria de trabajo y pienso y si yo
no soy el perfil que están buscando
estos escenarios negativos que nosotros
nos ponemos nos frenan y no nos dejan
dar lo mejor de nosotros mismos esto se
replica al ámbito empresarial y de
emprendimiento quizás lo que les comenté
hoy día les suene un poco familiar y es
que llega un momento en nuestra vida que
nosotros pensamos que estamos preparados
para emprender o pensamos que tenemos
una buena idea para emprender y
generalmente buscamos a alguien de
nuestro entorno ya sea un amigo o
alguien de nuestra familia y empezamos a
contarle vamos a suponer que este globo
es nuestro depósito de sueño y empezamos
a contarle de qué
tengo una idea para hacer x servicio
o se me ocurrió realizar tal producto
y qué es lo que sucede cuando ellos nos
dan una devolución de nuestra idea
generalmente nos dicen no no creo que
funciona en bolivia y empezamos
he visto algo similar y no ha funcionado
o no no creo que de porque la situación
del país no es la mejor y nuestro sueño
quedan desinflados ojo nos ha tocado a
nosotros estar de ese lado de desinflar
los sueños de alguien
s
ese factor de pensar negativamente viene
en nuestro caso que hemos estudiado en
bolivia desde la escuela quizás a
ustedes recuerden
nos enseñan cuántas guerras cuántas
batallas hemos perdido
hablamos de deporte hablamos de fútbol y
nos dicen no eso no lo nuestro no se
olviden que seguimos viviendo el
recuerdo de la clasificación de la
selección del mundial del 94 y estamos
pensando que ha hecho la selección del
94 para llegar al mundial y decimos no
no creo que vayamos a mundial en un
tiempo cercano entonces qué sucede
tendemos a victimizar no por ser
boliviano o por ser latino alguna vez
has escuchado que hay un buen jugador de
fútbol o un buen deportista y dicen
muchas se hayan nacido en brasil en
argentina haya sido millonario entonces
nosotros tendemos a victimizar no y ese
es el primer punto que quiero tocarles
hoy día y es que nosotros tenemos que
cambiar la mentalidad tenemos que
confiar en nosotros mismos no
si nosotros empezamos a confiar en
nosotros mismos nosotros es como que hay
antes habíamos estado vendados por los
escenarios negativos cuando confiamos en
que nosotros tenemos muchas habilidades
y que podemos lograr muchas cosas es
como que coloquemos un dron sobre
nuestra cabeza y empecemos a sobrevolar
y tengamos una visión panorámica dejemos
de mirar sesgado y eso nos va a permitir
que podamos crecer y avanzar me pasó en
mi vida como estaba trabajando en una
empresa de manera dependiente yo soñaba
con emprender le contaba a algunos
amigos de emprender y las respuestas
eran no no creo que la situación del
país sea buena no si está con un sueldo
cómodo y entonces en vez de dar un paso
para adelante me mantenía en mi zona de
confort mismo o quizá medio para atrás
no eso sucedió hasta el 30 de noviembre
de 2015 cuando por reestructuración en
la compañía deciden despedirme
ese clic de ese factor externo hizo de
que yo cambie mi mentalidad hizo que
cambie la forma en cómo pensaba y creía
en lo que yo era capaz fue así que fundé
mi primera compañía de base tecnológica
una empresa de desarrollo de software en
el cuarto de soltero de la casa de mis
padres con una tablet prestada por en
aquel entonces mi novia y mi actual
esposa y fueron tres meses donde me
dediqué a buscar los contactos que tenía
en mi libreta de contactos y mis redes
sociales escribiéndole a mis amigos y
conocidos ofreciéndoles mis servicios
los tres meses no vendí un solo peso
se acerca a mi padre y me dice ariel qué
te parece si buscas un trabajo y le digo
pero estoy trabajando y me dice no un
trabajo de verdad durante paguen y le
digo por supuesto él no me lo decía por
por desinflar mis sueños ni por
desalentar me es más considero que mi
padre es una de las personas que más ha
confiado en mí y confía en mí lo decía
en ese momento como un padre preocupado
por ver de qué yo no generaba ingresos
pero ya llegué a cambiar mi mentalidad y
había tenido ese chip de que ya yo podía
lograr cosas grandes gracias a dios hoy
día después de cuatro años puedo decir
que lo hicimos porque tenemos un equipo
que acompañó en este proceso que usamos
la frontera del país llamamos la
atención de medios internacionales de
los más importantes del mundo e hicimos
cosas grandes entonces tenemos que
cambiar nuestra mentalidad tenemos que
soñar en grande pero tenemos que hacer
que esas cosas sucedan justamente ese es
el segundo punto que quiero tocarles hoy
día y es que tenemos que ejecutar
tenemos que poner manos a la obra
tenemos que hacer que esas cosas sucedan
muchas veces nos pasa que empezamos a
idealizar proyectos empezamos a soñar
con proyectos con ideas pero no las
materializamos hay una frase que me
gusta mucho y es una buena idea sin
ejecución es una alucinación me sucedió
en mi vida cuando estaba creciendo la
empresa empezaron a hacerme muchas ideas
y en un momento dado me vi envuelto en
casi cinco proyectos al mismo tiempo
pero los proyectos no estaban siendo
ejecutados así que decidí enfocarme para
que los proyectos sucedan se hagan
realidad así es que les aconsejo que
usen una metodología que es el producto
mínimo viable y nosotros en nuestro caso
hacíamos del macro del producto buscamos
algo pequeño dando así un valor
diferenciador y lanzamos el producto por
ejemplo si yo quisiera abrir un
restaurante de una comida fusión de
cochabamba y de santacruz y mi idea de
proyectos restaurante es que sea una
infraestructura grande un menú con 15
items quizás voy a tardar 8 meses 10
meses 12 meses en realizar el proyecto
pero si yo digo qué tal si en vez de
hacerlo todo completo hago un menú de
tres ítems empieza a vender con delivery
o por internet y le muestro el concepto
que quiero darle a los consumidores es
algo rápido y a bajo costo entonces yo
les recomiendo que traten cuando
empiecen un proyecto de
salir rápido y a bajo costo nosotros lo
hacemos por nuestros emprendimientos
ahora de base tecnológica pero nos
enfocamos en darle un valor
diferenciador al usuario entonces ese es
justamente el punto que yo quiero
dejarle al final es de que pensemos
fuera de la caja es que hagamos las
cosas de una manera diferente en que
dejemos de ser tradicionales o por
costumbre o que por procesos se hacen
las cosas así nos ha tocado seguramente
a todos alguna vez escuchar o preguntar
por qué se hace así no porque siempre 6
no tenemos que volvernos personas que
cuestionemos tenemos que volvernos
personas que innovemos el país necesita
emprendedores e innovadores es decir
entre innovadores entonces hace unos
días me tocó acompañar a mi hermano al
banco en santa cruz
y después de 30 minutos hacer una
escuela del autobanco nos toca que nos
atienda la cajera nos saluda y nos
pregunta qué vamos a hacer mi hermano el
alcanza su carnet y le dice que quería
retirar dinero de su cuenta
ella le pregunta si él había cambiado su
carné de identidad y mi hermano responde
que sí que había renovado su carnet para
sorpresa nuestra ella nos dice que no
podía realizar la transacción porque
tenía mi hermano que pasara plataforma
para actualizar sus datos y mi hermano
le dice pero si mi nombre sigue siendo
el mismo mi número de carnet sigue
siendo el mismo mi fecha nacimiento
sigue siendo el mismo y ella le dice sí
pero la fecha de vencimiento de su
carnet es diferente
puede sonar gracioso pero así fue por
supuesto mi hermano le dijo que no que
le de su carnet
nos fuimos uso la aplicación móvil
transfirió a otro banco y en otro banco
puedo hacer la transacción sin ningún
problema si ella le preguntamos por qué
no puede ser atrás la transacción no va
a decir que por un proceso del banco si
alguien le preguntamos de arriba no es
que porque alguien se lo dijo pero
seguimos haciendo las cosas de una
manera tradicional seguimos haciendo las
cosas de una manera por costumbre nos
pasó igual en un emprendimiento que
estamos por lanzar de base tecnológica
en el sector de salud cuando empezamos
a ciertas personas nos decían de que no
veía de que vaya a tener éxito porque en
el sector salud se maneja de una manera
muy tradicional
nosotros por supuesto continuamos con el
proyecto continuamos pensando diferente
y cuando empezamos a lanzar los
productos mínimos viables a los actores
del ecosistema la retroalimentación de
ellos era guau ya era hora de que
digitalice mos y llegue la
transformación al área de la salud con
la tecnología entonces que les quiero
decir con esto tienen que pensar
diferentes tienen que ser innovadores
tienen que hacer cosas diferentes porque
en nuestro país hay mucho talento así
que dejemos de suponer y comencemos a
emprender
[Música]